and we'll be discussing that and more
during the press preview
our first look at tomorrow's front pages
tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the new statesman's
political editor stephen bush
and the spectators economics
correspondent kate andrews a very good
evening
to both of you chat to them in a moment
first of all let's check out some of
those front pages for you starting with
the
sun we got a glimpse of it earlier
leading with an exclusive that prince
harry
has arrived in the uk to attend the
funeral of his grandfather
prince philip it's headline dash harry
the mail quotes the countess of wessex
describing the final moments of her
father-in-law the duke of edinburgh
the metro takes a similar approach using
the words of prince andrew
calling the duke's absence a huge void
in the queen's life
and it's a similar theme for the
telegraph
the financial times says china is to
start mixing and
matching covered vaccines and doses amid
fears that the vaccines it's producing
itself
may not be effective enough and research
by the guardian has found that nearly 42
percent of black people age 16 to 24
are currently unemployed three times
more
than their white counterparts
and we're joined tonight by stephen bush
and kate andrews
great to see you both thank you very
much for joining us this sunday evening
kate why don't we start with the front
of the daily telegraph a lovely
photograph
there of the queen tributes of course
coming in from around the globe and
we've heard today
from prince andrew prince edward and a
statement from
princess anne yes we've gotten more
information from the royal family today
about
how grief is being handled within the
royal family and how phillips passing
has impacted them all and and the big
quote that's being carried on the front
pages tonight is from the duke of york
saying that his passing has left a huge
void in the queen's life now
this is not surprising in the slightest
they had a marriage that lasted for
over 70 years but you know uh naturally
very very sad and
painful to hear nonetheless uh we've
also um had other comments um learning
more about his passing
we're told from the countess of wessex
that it was a peaceful passing
and you know which is which is much more
positive to hear despite the very
difficult circumstances
and i suspect we'll just be getting more
and more of this information as the week
goes on leading up to his funeral and of
course as we
turn to look to the sun prince harry has
returned as well and perhaps the
politics around his returning as
as well as the the overwhelming grief on
on top of that
for the family but what i really picked
up from the front page of the telegraph
is the extent to which the royal family
members themselves are saying we're so
grateful
for the tributes that are being paid
around the world to prince philip you
know coming from
top political leaders diplomats and but
also from the general public which have
just been pouring out
uh with their support for the royal
family in this time yeah stephen very
rare to
see members of the royal family speaking
publicly
so personally as we saw today outside
the chapel
in windsor and i guess one of the
reasons is that because the public are
being asked to stay away
and not to go and gather outside windsor
castle or buckingham palace
the royal family feel that they want to
get that message out there that they're
very grateful for all the
the love and support they've received
yes i think it's partly than it's the
old circumstances of the coronavirus
means people who want to
pay their best wishes cannot do so in a
normal way
but i mean also although it's very rare
it's also very rare for the
prince consul to uh to have died at all
in
yeah the longest-serving prince consort
it's very rare for our
head of state uh to die of course
because it's a hereditary
uh monarchy so i think it everything
feels very strange and weird simply
because this is
this is an event which within most
people's lifetimes hasn't happened
uh yeah a marriage longer than the
average lifespan uh when they got
married so it
is a huge event obviously a huge void as
everyone says in the life of the queen
but a huge event in the life of the
country as well
let's move on to that story you
mentioned a moment ago on the front of
the
sun the sun calling it an exclusive
prince is back
prince harry arrives in the uk ahead of
uh the dukes funeral dash harry
is the headline they've uh they've gone
with um
kate it was interesting uh listening to
sir john major
today former prime minister of course he
was guardian to princes william and
harry
after their mother's death and he said
he hoped it would end
any friction between the pair this talk
that the brothers may well walk behind
the coffin of the duke of edinburgh do
you think that
is something that could happen because
we know it's their relationship has been
strained
well it's a very strange circumstance
talking about family problems on a
national and international scale because
at the end of the day that is exactly
what this is it is a
family dispute um and difficulty across
the board um from
many different perspectives and it is
moments like this in great tragedy where
people tend to put those issues aside
and do i think that all of this can be
solved over the course of the next few
days well
probably not and the emphasis isn't
going to be on the oprah winfrey
interview it's not going to be on the
falling out
over the past year it's going to be on
memory uh
serving memory to prince philip um i
would expect for everybody
to put those issues aside and to try to
get along now
could there be opportunity for some
healing one would certainly hope so it's
these moments that
tend to bring us together and you know
it's notable that prince harry is going
to be following
quarantine protocol he won't be out of
quarantine if he chooses to do
his five-day test and release until
right before the funeral so
we don't know how much the royal family
will even be seeing of each other this
week when it comes to prince harry
but certainly for the funeral and around
all of this you usually expect to put
family
squabble aside and and whilst it has
been you know an international
spectacle for this family in this moment
that is what it is
steve in front of the guardian now very
interestingly the guardian has no
mention of the duke of edinburgh at all
on its front page i think it's pretty
much the only paper well it is the only
paper that i've seen
not to do that but what they are talking
about are those words from the prime
minister that i mentioned a few moments
ago that warning
from boris johnson look tomorrow uh we
want to
enjoy ourselves we want to start getting
back to some sort of normality
but we have to be careful he said i urge
everyone to continue to behave
responsibly and remember hands face
space and fresh air
yeah and it's actually that no that last
of what last intensity is the most
important fresh air
we now know a lot a great deal about how
the coronavirus spreads it mainly
spreads
uh through airborne trans transmission
which is why if you have to be in an
indoor space open the windows
get open the doors if you can get some
ventilation going
um and one of the things that has
perhaps not been
ideal about government messaging is it's
taken quite a while to
to update that i think we've all at some
point over the past year being in a
space described as
covered safe where um it's got a lot of
perspex greens which to be honest you
might as well put a rosary up for all
the good it'll do stopping
the spread of the coronavirus so i think
it's a very timely and very useful
message and hopefully we'll start to see
people
uh doing more things and actually are
covered safe unless things are about
kind of
covered security theater first thing
you're looking forward to the most
stephen is
please tell me it's a haircut it's
definitely yeah
it's very definitely a um i actually
need to get my act together and book it
i realize um
because it obviously is gonna require
quite quite some doing uh you know
a 10-man team really to just everest
excellent we look forward to seeing the
results uh very soon
um kate you're an economics
correspondent i mean many businesses
will be
nervous tomorrow won't they um it's
something that's reflected on the front
of the daily telegraph
um as stephen was saying pubs and
restaurants fall foul of covered rules
over outdoor spaces we mustn't forget
that of course
we're all talking about wanting to go
and enjoy having a drink and a meal in a
pub
garden but many many pubs simply won't
be able to open
because they haven't got any outdoor
space or maybe because financially they
just have
been so hit that that they're not able
to
yeah you hit the nail on the head there
jonathan because there are multiple
aspects to this and
first of all many of us will be looking
forward to getting our hair cut and
having a pint for
many others this is about their business
it's about their livelihood it's about
where their income comes from so
the ability to reopen is absolutely
crucial for them as individuals and also
contributing
to the wider economy but as the
telegraph highlights here many
businesses are concerned
that this is going to be regulated in a
very heavy-handed way
the idea is that you can reopen as long
as 50
or more of the space is open to the
fresh air so it's not walled in or
closed in
and some places that have walls in their
pub gardens for example are concerned
they're going to be told actually
this doesn't count now hopefully stephen
says that emphasis on fresh air as long
as this is a well ventilated space
that should really be the main priority
and the main cause of concern
if an area weren't to have that so
hopefully the regulation around this
won't be so
tight as to want to just shut down what
pubs are doing but to make sure
that it really is operating in a safe
way the other thing of course to
highlight is that
the majority of hospitality is going to
have to wait many many more weeks before
it can reopen because
and they don't have the opportunity to
serve outside
so there's still huge amounts of
pressure especially on the hospitality
industry but really on business across
the board
um as they wait many many weeks longer
to be able to open up having been shot
now of course
for months um so i would you know say
that while this is a very
uh wonderful time from a socializing
point of view and certainly
you know good news for the economy it's
only the beginning we have a very very
long way to go before we
start to resemble normal yeah and just
very briefly kate staying with you i
mean
the pa the prime minister has said that
this will be irreversible or he wants it
to be irreversible
is that your thinking as well
well he certainly wants it to be
irreversible and all of the cover data
right now
looks really positive when you're
looking at infection rates
hospitalization and death it's all
plummeted
and if we look at the percentage of
people who are estimated to have
antibodies across the uk
and how that correlates with vaccines
all of this information tells us what
you know we already instinctively knew
which is that vaccines work and so as
long as we keep getting jabbed hopefully
the information
stays positive but the prime minister
has decided to take
that most cautious approach because he
really doesn't want to have to roll back
this is a prime minister who's
fundamentally uncomfortable with the
idea of lockdown
slightly ironic because you know we have
had one of the strictest lockdowns in
the developed worlds
for months now but we know he's
uncomfortable with it and the last thing
he wants
is to bring us back into it so while
he's probably not delighted with the
timeline
taking so long he prefers that over
having to reinstate lockdown
yet again yeah and stephen do you think
people will obey the rules tomorrow do
you think people are going to go crazy
and and and sort of rush into shops rush
into pub gardens i mean do you think
that on the whole
it's going to be perhaps a more cautious
approach maybe people aren't ready to
to rush back to doing these things that
we've not been doing for so long
yeah i think some people will definitely
feel a great deal of anxiety about
um returning to normal life and i think
unfortunately for some people they will
continue to feel that even after june
july even after
everyone has either received or been
offered a jab and that will be
a very difficult thing for us to go
through as a country we'll be returning
to normal
which some people find quite frightening
but no i think people will be quite
cautious
partly because most pubs will be closed
it will be a very weird and different
experience
i think also a lot of people who've kind
of deliberately tuned out of the news
because of how depressing the last year
are kind of just waiting until um june
to sort of let it all hang out in sort
of one big bash rather than
necessarily knowing the detail of what
unlocks between then and now
also when the weather's a bit better i
mean it could be pretty chilly sitting
in a pub garden for a few hours couldn't
in the next few
days thank you both for the moment we'll
speak again shortly because coming up
china says it's okay to mix different
varieties
of kovid vaccine we'll be discussing
that and more in a couple minutes
hello again part two of the press
preview still with me stephen bush and
kate andrews uh stephen uh why don't we
start with you this time
financial times china to mix and match
jabs after worries
over home-grown vaccines talk us through
this
right so this is a very important story
because so
after concerns within china than some of
the vaccines that have been developed
domestically don't work
they are going to switch towards uh
vaccines that they've bought in
which will mean sort of well not quite
double jabs triple jabs in some cases
right and then
if you've had a chinese jab and the
government now feels is not good enough
you'll get a second of whether it's
pfizer johnson johnson modern or
whatever and then of course your second
jab of that
now this is positive in a way and then
it obviously is an adjustment to
something not working to something which
does it does marginally increase
the risk of some kind of
vaccine-resistant mutation
but uh but that is essentially the kind
of the most significant thing is is the
switch
away from from domestically produced
vaccines which of course will also
increase the scrabble for vaccine
supplies
not really a direct issue here at home
but a big issue in terms of
the big questions about when you can
fully reopen in terms of
domestic flight uh international flights
end of international quarantine
all of the other sort of challenges of
lockdown which have a big economic here
even though of course for most of us we
don't directly experience those
consequences
yeah kate this article talks about chile
which has relied heavily on
china's jab for its vaccination program
now it's done
pretty well with its vaccination program
but we know it's really struggling in
terms of
infection rates yeah this is a really
important point because chile's become
really the international example of what
could potentially
happen if you still vaccinate but open
up and then
infection rates go up and but something
that isn't often spoken about at least
certainly not in the top headlines is
the fact that chile has been very
reliant on the cineback jab
now it's recently been discovered that
they think that after one jab you
actually barely get any protection at
all it takes two jobs
to get a certain level of protection and
even then it's just thought to be over
50
which is one of the least effective uh
approved jobs
internationally that we have so far so
the differences between a job like
cinevac and job like pfizer
oxford astrazeneca is really substantial
and that is a big part of what's
happening in chile so just to take
what's happening there
and say well we can transplant it here
there are other mitigating factors that
have to be
taken into account i think this is also
an important story when we look at it
from the perspective of vaccine
diplomacy
china and russia have been very eager to
ship their vaccines often in the hopes
that they'll be making friends around
the world by doing so
but if those vaccines aren't as
effective and if they're not working
as desired well that's going to be a
very different ball game really than if
you're shipping off jobs perhaps
slightly later
and as america and other parts of the
west decided to do but are working more
effectively
and so i think a lot of this has to do
with the vaccine diplomacy race as much
as it has to do with what's happening at
home
good point and let's finish with uh the
metro stephen david cameron he's finally
released a statement it's been a long
time coming hasn't it
do you think this will be enough for his
critics to be satisfied this is all
about his uh his lobbying
that uh that he did um labour's still
calling for an investigation his critics
probably unlikely to go away
yeah i mean i think if anything this
deepens the problem right he is now from
his own mouth said
oh i shouldn't have done this but i
haven't broken any rules which of course
uh then immediately raises questions
about the quality of the
uh rules on lobbying that we currently
have uh
i think it only will embolden his
critics but most importantly in the
opposition but of course his critics
across politics to say look well even
he's admitted it so yeah i think this
story has
has somewhere yet to run kate
yeah i agree with steven and i think
also given the very specific context
of coronavirus um those loans in the
furlough scheme were intentionally made
very easy to access and the idea was
that any company that might take
advantage of that
and you know would be certainly frowned
upon to say the least and
the idea that the former prime minister
was reaching out to current cabinet
members
to be talking about a company and giving
that company help
which has now collapsed i think is going
to raise further questions as well and
as stephen says the fact that he's
acknowledged that he should have done
things differently
probably isn't going to help yeah i'm
sure it's not the the end of the matter
kate stephen thank you very much indeed
we'll chat again in half an hour also
and just to say that if you've missed
any of the press preview tonight it will
be available
shortly and indeed every night on our
youtube channel